The Boy and the Baker by Vaz
An elderly baker walking to his shop sees a boy being bullied and beaten by a gang of older children.
He shouts and the children run off.
He goes to the boy who is bruised and shaken.
The baker puts his arm around him and brings him into his shop.
Once inside he asks the boy,
Where are your parents?
The boy meekly replies,
I have no parents. I'm all alone.
The baker sees a lost look in the boy's eyes.
He understands the boy is one of many countless children who are abandoned and alone,
left to live on the streets fending for themselves.
Like so many, he has no family, no experience, just a tenuous and dangerous future.
The kind-hearted baker asks him if he'd like to help him make bread.
The boy nods his head and the baker takes him into his kitchen.
The boy watches as the baker assembles the ingredients, puts them in a bowl and mixes them together.
He sprinkles flour on a wooden table and begins kneading the dough.
Once he finished, he placed the dough in a pan and covered it with a towel.
Curious, the boy asks,
Why do you do this?
The baker replied,
Once the dough has formed, it needs time to rest and grow.
After the dough had risen, the baker placed the uncooked bread into the oven.
They both watch as the bread begins to rise as it cooks.
The dough transforms into a brown, crusty, aromatic morsel of delight.
This is a miracle of life, the baker says,
How the bread rises to nourish our bodies and help us grow.
The baker smiles at the boy and gives him the bread as a gift.
The boy thanks the baker and exits the shop, returning to the streets.
Not far from the baker's shop, he finds an alley where he can rest and eat the bread.
The next morning, as the baker arrives at his shop,
he spots a crowd of people watching as a policeman arrests a boy.
The baker runs to him and asks,
What has the boy done?
He replies,
The boy killed a man.
The baker, not understanding, follows them to the police station.
The boy is taken into the back, and the baker asks the jailer,
May I speak with the boy?
The jailer nods and gives his approval.
Once in the cell, he asks,
What happened to my boy?
The boy replies,
When I went to eat the bread, the others saw what I had.
They attacked me, and during the fight one of the boys was severely injured.
I guess he must have died.
I don't know how it happened, but I was the only one there when the policeman arrived.
After a few days, the boy was taken before a judge.
In the courtroom, no one was there to speak for the boy,
only the baker, alone sitting in the back.
The boy was found guilty and convicted of murder.
With a stern look, the judge sentenced him to death.
On the day of his execution, the boy received a visitor.
It was the kind-hearted baker with a loaf of bread in his hand.
The boy, seeing his only friend, begins to cry.
The baker smiles at him, and in a reassuring voice says,
Do you remember the night in my shop when we baked bread?
Yes, the boy replies.
I spoke of the miracle of the bread.
Well, there is a second miracle.
You saw how the bread rose once in the pan and rose again in the oven?
He nodded yes.
Be strong, my son. You too shall rise like this bread.
Bread is the body of Christ from which all gain nourishment and life.
Amen.